and speaking of making a difference what  none of you know is that my first guest  today was supposed to be actor and  comedian Kevin Hart and so yeah so as  many of you know Kevin was seriously  injured in a car accident he's okay in  recovering but because Kevin couldn't be  here one of his good friends stepped the  heck up and I love him um cuz I got real  nervous my first show it's like I was  like I am so sorry you're sick oh oh I  call it all friends I'm like anyway he  left his honeymoon to come here this is  real left his honeymoon his wife hates  me to come here and take Kevin's place  and this is very exciting for me I  apologize in advance if I can't talk for  a few minutes though that's the lie I  can talk all the time then everything  but you know my first guest and this is  my first guest ever from his HBO show  ballers from The Fast and the Furious  movies and  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]